to Spielberg films in one weekend life
could be worse
I'm just saying warhorse
now warhorse is about a horse who's a
farm horse that becomes a war horse and
when you see the trailer you're like I
have no idea I don't know but then the
reality of the situation is whenever you
have a drama and you put a horse in it
usually good I don't know why there's
something about those creatures that
just make for good movies I guess it's
almost like ever since they killed that
big horse and animal farm they were like
all right we'll give horses their
shining day for the next five decades so
the main story in this movie is not the
horse owner because there's like five in
the movie what I like about this horses
this horse is one of those unbridled
types you know it's just like you know
what don't put a harness on me I'm too
awesome I'm like Shadowfax Oh Liam Brown
so war is breaking out in Europe and
this horse just ends up going everywhere
you know this movie kind of reminded me
of it's like Forrest Gump with a horse
it's the horses life the horse goes
everywhere it sees more awesome stuff
than we ever will in our lives and
everyone sees this horse and they're
like this horse is so awesome I just
like this horse you know what that's my
horse I will take care of that horse and
they do and they get attached and
somehow I'm not gonna tell you however
that horse ends up moving on to another
place and it ends up giving you a
perspective from other people's lives
you know other people who are on other
sides of this war I like seeing that
perspective that was really cool was
this one scene in the movie I don't want
to ruin it for you because it was one of
those things where I was like that is
really cool you don't really usually see
that in war movies I liked it that was
Spielberg is hit and miss sometimes you
know if he tries to take something
that's kind of unique and be like okay
I'm gonna take this concept we're gonna
make it relatable sometimes you get a
great movie sometimes you get a I turns
out War Horse is a great movie and some
part since his original owner still
looking for him you know he's trying to
find him and whatnot everyone falls in
love with this horse business original
owners like dude no I love this horse I
love this horse about as much as that
one chick from Star Trek for love the
whales really loves that horse so that
whole aspect a couple of times reminded
me of americantale
I don't know why it just did it's good
it's emotional it's touching there are
times you will want to cry to an absurd
degree it's the right man just let it
out I will say this movie is worth
buying on blu-ray it's a family-friendly
kind of movie but there are a couple of
parts where you're like oh man that's
brutalist that's an animal there are
parts would people die too but for some
reason that doesn't bother you know
you're like oh yeah people dead it
happens all the time the animal so to
Spielberg movies this weekend - really
good
movies this weekend not bad for
Christmas I must say so your favorite
spielberg drama
what is it comment below let me know and
as always if you like what you've seen
here and you want to see more click
right here to see more
[Music]